si l'on passe au blind test spécial
bouffe pour sébastien on répond la
lumière en mettant les ciels bouffe
messieurs spécial bouffe parce qu'avec
le danger avant de faire diriger non non
je fais pas de régime on y va il faut
trouver le nom il faut trouver le nom
soit du chanteur ont peu joué et joue
tout le monde joue le chanteur soit soit
du chanteur soit de la chanson d'accord
répandez fois à noisy béziers premier ce
sont les cornichons bras mais attention
attention didier deuxième morceau braver
les choristes dj laisse courir un peu
didier
s'il vous plaît
non
et puis
mgr williams est tellement après
troisième chanson attention c'est moi du
coup ce que je chéris bazar oui jouer
lucciana s'est joué mais je ne joue
jamais sur ce soir était à charles
trenet ou c'est un bonheur les chansons
alors on continue didier prochaine
chanson je suis concentré vous elle
faisait chauffer désolé c'est sébastien
pas ce qu'il a dit d'abord j'ai bien
créé avec cette île falardeau tout de
suite on continue sa série léa blair il
ne manque que ça c'est énorme je viens
talibans dos aussi je crois que tu as
pleuré c'est dur je sais c'est encore
lui qui
human yahoo
comment s'appelle sont de la haye
c'est la chanson de l'été non non merci
oui valérie lemercier goûter mexique
ouais là tu sais c'est bien maintenant
une chanson pour notre ami michel polac
didier souple j'entraîne confites manon
c'est parti oui c'est dacia mon futur
attends je suis retraité mais c'est mon
métier
depuis que celui-ci lui parle de livres
dans la confiture les playlists j'y
arriverai un peu le fera la prochaine
fois je dirais la première phrase d'un
livret est oxydé vitesse à la sismique
l'insipide pardon hein confiture sinon
ouais non maintenant et l'huile et
roumains ont été plus forts que j'ai vu
jusqu'à maintenant on continue ça c'est
une chanson pour toi patrick on y va
ces sucettes france gall yann moix on
continue didier nature
cette fois il fait la gueule
voilà un bon joueur de blind test
l'afrique sébastien j'adore ça j'ai
écouté j'ai fait que ça écouter les
chansons dans ma vie mais c'est fermé
imitation mais à chacun son truc en même
temps rouaix
alors quand tu retiens génial a vraiment
j'ai jamais vu ça lasse l'avait annoncé
ce qu'ils gagnent rien il ya de ma
considération
c'est déjà beaucoup j'ai déjà laurent
contini l'a déjà oui on continue
bravo bravo pour l'applaudir
ouais ouais ouais
bon je vais pas la dernière à éviter
mais bon j'y crois c'est comme à la télé
on peut rallumer la lumière s'il vous
plaît bien on va faire un blind test
[Musique]
alors le blind test aujourd'hui maxime
vous connaissez le principe du blind
test vous y jouer tout le temps au pc au
modem tests n'ont donc alors le principe
le principe du beurre qu'est ce que
c'est ça non me parle pas de secte le
principe du blind test c'est très simple
tout le monde le connaît pour connaître
la chanson aux premières mesures aux
premières notes et là on a pris les
jours de la semaine le thème c'est les
jours de la semaine
s'il vous plaît non non le public après
nicolas sirkis
mais avant elle
mais je te vois pas les moyens avant
attend si c'est vraiment ce qu'il dit
c'est donc c'est vous réduirez voyage
permanent
c'est sophie duez bien attention le
publie je vous explique comment on joue
vous laisser répondre les invités est si
les invités répondent pas après
effectivement vous levez la main vous
venez ici tu veux vite je n'ai star le
mardi
donnez-moi groupe
[Musique]
les mains des rebelles les pretenders ne
trouvez pas c'est fly une requête sont
bons alors banque publique ya quelqu'un
qui a dit ça venez ici
bravo mais pas passer les mammas bravo
vous me faites la bulle si vous êtes une
star ce soir là comme on ne sait pas
s'il n'est pas passé les malades
je suis très déçu comme on ne
connaissait pas des tapas et elle est
morte en s'étranglant la grosse la mama
cass c'est la barre qui s'est passé
lundi
c'est lundi dans mon lit je suis garant
oui on peut remettre un petit bouquet du
père monsieur eddy envies de bébé
[Musique]
là c'est très très dur très très dur le
manceau qui vient
[Musique]
moi je connais pas
la veillée là mais c'est vous qui l'avez
le dira elle est incroyable à l'effort
temps leonardo dicaprio bon football et
ans il était une fois en dix catégories
très très extraordinaire éclectique
comme c'est très éclectique quoi c'est
qui qui chantait c'était une fois
sublime et là s'en souviennent chanson
suivante
[Musique]
m
ce vendredi là je donne à des sommets
par bowie sur financent normalement
[Musique]
personne c'est que vous savez vous savez
qui c'est madame non même si vous savez
vous pouvez venir même si vous savez pas
qui c'est vous même je vais pas vous non
ces fraudeurs my mind 6 gbit [ __ ] de
français c'est pas français ça anime
exhibits et les apaches cette satanée
avec laon nesat a démarré samedi soir tu
me lis pas les marchés de chansons
numéro suivante
je te rappelle comment ça s'appelle pas
s'attendre non tu attendais
chouette appartement que mon père s'il
m'a effectivement en moins on a de
confort au maximum aux bruyères à
l'ascenseur 17 20 ce n'est pas la partie
intense et c'est toute la classe a et b
seront écoutés oui mais moi je suis
juste à kastoria modernes ont cessé le
début des banlieues ce à quoi je crois
pas ça me réussit pas dimanche en libye
il a dit à ma venue
c'est une star c'est gilbert bécaud
appellera gilbert bécaud et messieurs
bonjour voila regarder la caméra facile
[Musique]
ça s'appelle comment le bal du nord les
jeux c'est à qui sortait des bals du
samedi au dinar bon c'est pas les bals
populaires donc non bon luis enrique
d'opcvm chansons des balcons les
baltimore
[Musique]
dimanche après dimanche matin non un
niveau élevé enfin dimanche alger non
les millionnaires du dimanche
celui-là n'était pas facile et personnes
à gagner je peux vous le dire moi qui a
gagné non je me levais je me verrais tu
dors en quoi ces deux là bas bonjour
l'ambiance
donc on a fait un blind test spécial
perle noire
donc ce ne sont que des chanteuses
noires exceptionnel attention en didier
et pour animer le blind test et surtout
l'arbitré philippe corti
messieurs
bonsoir fuite alors que nous c'était
perle noire j'ai trouvé que ça faisait
un potentiel de michel que des mecs
j'avais des filles à toi je me sentais
bien dans l'émission comme ça années
définis c'est une très bonne idée on
attend surtout milan songe ou par équipe
donc à l'équipe des oranje ont rien
l'équipe des bleus vous savez ce que je
vous demande c'est l'interprète laurent
baffie le sait je ne demande pas le
titre de la chanson je demande
l'interprète et ce ne sont que des
perles noires comme toi et les ballons
ok on y va didier meynard aussi
bon ben on a omis obi-1 est un produit
mois volet qui le perdra alors on a
besoin de gagner des perles noires
c'est génial on qu'on arrête le point
d'accès aux mini gagné bravo merci
deuxième chanson didier dauriac généraux
égyptiens bas volant
un diamant
et suprême
[Musique]
bien bien bien alors pour le moment un
point de chaque côté un haut visible à
filles vous sauver l'honneur de vos
équipes respectives
didier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai qu'elle est bonne les bleus
deux points les oranje un point mais
d'antan à paris parce qu'il agit de foix
jean rostand s'était pas aller quand
c'était rapady alors en carton jaune on
me dit un truc
attention soyons sérieux
attention monsieur didier dauriac et
nord
[Musique]
ah non non non non je suis la pompe est
prouvé que ce n'est pas tricher je suis
la bible barthou vous jouez par et qui
attention là c'est beaucoup plus
difficile c'est la même chanson je veux
l'interprète
là
c'est un honneur
mais là
py non reconduit à dire
aussi
révélations
un gardien
formidable comme dirait à lille est
formidable comme dirait gildas
magnifique comme j'ai réducteur bravo
c'est toujours lui un et je joue pour
les oranje donc bravo quand tu joues
pour les oranje
austin et jézabel commandes toujours
eric il s'appelle du journal
bien très bien ok c'est le fond à la
télé aussi aisée alors on continue
bravo bravo dont le salaire est à 3 2
c'est quoi la répons cake tic
on continue la même chanson je veux
l'interprète didier
non non
ces gens-là conflit le quartier jackson
jeudi etc
ouais bravo bravo tu l'as lu avant on le
dit avant ici ici avant
je ne crois pas
si simplement
quand tu sors
je suis le premier acheteur de la
première place c'est moi qui l'a achetée
alors
la lavande ou rennes
ainsi avant d'une place il a gagné le
sourire il a gagné le chêne à l'avant
mais se connaissent très chauvine
il est génial accor qui en
blaxploitation était vraiment génial
je vais toujours c'est ça oui c'est un
truc voilà donc les bleus 2 les oranje 4
ça va pas très fort du jour angers
ballon s'il vous plaît didier
[Musique]
encore naïve et milongas féminine sima
de l'homme
[Musique]
bien six relaxes et 6 pouces en souffre
le bal public
[Musique]
qui a dit donna summer municipaux de
faire ton et s'annule le point dans mes
seins nus le jeu sam il a raison ce qui
a dit ça qui est du salut le jeu non
mais copiable viens viens viens
maintenant qu allissa bien c'est qu'ils
n'ont certainement pas lui
[Applaudissements]
la route
c'est toi promotionnelle ici bon ok tu
n'aurais pas dû dire ça or escale sellem
qui est sur scène avec laurent baffie
dans cette pièce je le je déteste parce
que on continue didier bernard
[Applaudissements]
attention sans son numéro je sais plus
combien didier ça c'est dur c'est beau
mais c'est dur salois palois la cuisse
et éclairaient le groupe coréen de
chansons d'antan
c'est vrai qu'il est leur nom oui très
gros ce gars là non
[Musique]
comment
je vais le stand
quoi
et oui mais le shérif qui est la fille
de john chéri le jazzman et qu'il a dit
heures de rigolade chili bravo les
enfants migrants je connaissais tout
neneh cherry
c'est très bien chanson alors 4 pour les
bleus 5 pour les oranges c'est très très
très proches
alors allons-y chanson numéro etc
d'harvard
le public ne souffle personne je n'ai
pas les bleus étaient donc nombreux
contacts didier
c'est une blague
whitney houston
tétouan le mariole là
[Musique]
oh
le ballon c'est là qu'ils n'ont aucun
amis tchèques adorent
[Applaudissements]
à
ce lexique chaka khan pour les bleus
chaka khan devant le bloc à cannes
si moi je suis premier c'est vrai
chaque élément
c'est en gt4 pour les bleus 7 pour les
anges
didier la croisière s'amuse davantage
c'est une perle noire
non non non là j'y crois plus facebook
j'y crois parce qu'ici j'ai cru lie à ta
famille tu appelles marvin et plein de
trucs mais jamais dire jamais je le
crois pas je n'ai pas pu enfin monsieur
je divise
bon alors maintenant maintenant c'est
très compliqué parce que celui enfin
seule équipe qui va trouver le titre à
l'interprète de la chanson qui vient
cette équipe a tout remporté je sais
c'est injuste mais la vie est injuste
c'est le super banco didier
on ne souffle pas gêné non je ne veux
pas que ça y est
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
quoi
m
bravo laurent bram ainsi bravo alors ben
il ya plus qu'une chose à faire avant la
fin de l'émission c'est le tatouage
d'ovidie et ce tatouage de anglade
à toi je me dis alors j'en ai deux à ya
des gens qui attendent depuis 11 heures
du soir pour voir le tatouage de libye
là je montre le petit haut et sinon y'a
pas moyen de jeter un coup d'oeil sur le
moteur merci à lui dit merci beaucoup
et maintenant passe au blind test à
blind test
et si un groupe
blanc était spécial route ont l'honneur
de bernard lavilliers
bonsoir ça
alors les équipes les équipes les
équipes on va faire aujourd'hui les
états unis contre la chine
d'accord j'ai reçu un email je suis une
bande de mecs ça m'avait dit qu'il me
demande si c'est vrai que korpi peu
scratcher avec son sac
oui c'est vrai je confirme je les
buffets revoilà didier l'internet
highway to hell et c'est l'effet waouh
le sida
très bien je me dis un deuxième chanson
m
mais
non
et voilà un point à droite un point
gauche attention ils ont marqué
attention je demandais pas ils ont des
lunettes qu'on tire assez bien organisé
oui bonsoir corps qui me l'a classé bien
préparer ces dix sont bien préparés
bravo serre c'est ce que j'appelle une
chambre bien produit la vigne et c'est
très bien
alors maintenant maintenant troisième
esso
19 ans
aulas
dans un sens je compte plutôt à
les bulldozers jamais dit les blues
brothers quand même hein il n'est pas
donné
je veux l'interprète beauté rassemblant
chaque fois
à
[Musique]
je suis le score a bien sûr je crois
pour des vacances
la preuve en fait pas pour nos jeunes on
voit ces décès sans interprète les
beatles ah non pardon j'ai mal tu sors
tu dégages la donne
4 en 4 1 4 à 3 tu dis des beatles et
millions d'amis chez les beatles i cento
john qu'est ce que tu vois à l'appel à
lunettes noires olalalala colloque la
cgt jeudi sur des passagers des pièces
moi mais c'est moi qui ai des
périphériques son contrôle vidéo c'est
baffie et ans et après évidemment être
un homme crédible et cétaphil répondu
voilà donc là c'est terrible à 5,1 à la
queue leu leu c'est une route on aurait
pu le passer sur c'est vrai
attention ces heurts
ce qu'on appelait ne sais pas s'ils
gagnent tout si vous êtes désarmés
n'aurait plus rien du tout attention
c'était didier
[Applaudissements]
ouais
sheila
m
glavine fait attention
on l'avait
alors il a dit john lannan après il à
dire une grosse star je suis désolé ce
n'est pas une réponse
ce sont les beatles en 8,6 à gagner de
près mais deux fois de suite le même
morceau c'est bien c'est bien pour
béatrice ardisson
oui on a pris toutes les musiques
français nous en envoyons influencé par
les bombardements continuent aussi du
français voici du français
[Musique]
m
ce chiffre monte à 7 pour les états unis
elle est arrivée à pied par la chine est
non attention vos petits pieds peuvent
revenir
l'interprète non répond c'est vous qui
s'y trouvent pas vous répondre et c'est
tout échappé
alité
et merci
c'est là
merci on a bien roulé a sûrement
mais original
pas assez bon
mais jusqu'ici ça je sais
photo na
[Musique]
j'avais moment avec vous êtes une star
ce soir là eric ken boothe bravo patrick
paris même si non paris 26 jan continuer
la lunette pour cadre le chemin de visa
tant de dérives et milieu de gamme
ton ami
3 3 7l remonte le niveau
alors heureusement qu'elle le rejoigne
et bien avec le super-banco pouvait tout
gagner
maintenant je suis père bongo c'est que
même si vous perdez on gagne c'est une
règle avant tout d'abord il ya une autre
chanson livre la torture
l'interprète
il est bon
des arrivants faire très mal
c'est bien
c'est toute la nuit c'est non bon alors
quatre pour vous êtes de ses malheurs de
radio lui et maintenant attention
maintenant attention le super bons coups
c'est à dire celui qui va remporter le
super banco va remporter le blind test
c'est ce que je sais c'est injuste mais
c'est comme ça la vie est injuste donc
la chanson parle de routes qui sont les
interprètes didier
machine
soir
0 c'est une france métissée qui gagne
c'est comme la coupe du monde
la belgique est dommage c'est comme le
rose c'est comme la coupe du monde il
contrôle et voilà
laetitia gagne et on gagne des gardes en
france bravo à tous les cas merci à se
repasser au blind test
et pour arbitrer et animer ce blind test
j'appelle monsieur philippe aubry
[Applaudissements]
et
c'est l'homme de l'est sur mon sort bien
alors
on est prêt les séries cultes de la télé
numéro 1 didier
yorkshire
le
non
suivant
à
là vous gagnez tout encore là les mecs
font des merveilles
qu'est ce que vous faites je vais aller
entre nous et on a pris pour vous exprès
des séries télé séries4 un gars exprès
pour vous avez dirigé tellement de
chaînes de télé qu'on sait déjà tout
gagné
qu'il avait dit alors ben fils suivante
[Musique]
des toiles
hors jeu
c'est qui qu'a subis cécilia qui a
répondu me dit catherine c'est tous les
deux voilà leurs débuts à l'épreuve
françois chessy gut et didier suivante
à l'été
ma vie
ils vont être contents non ça marchera
pas suivant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
bon je vais pas
salut
j'vois pas main
mannix
ce cas
[Musique]
les blues
aïe aïe aïe je n'avais que deux ils ont
huit suivants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
évidemment les inrockuptibles bas vous
étiez là bien et maintenant vous
connaissez la loi de cette émission
c'est très injuste mais la vie juste
celui qui va remporter le super banco
remportera le blind test donc ça veut
dire que même si vous avez deux ou trois
points vous pouvez quand même gagner à
condition de lidl ont concentré vous que
vous trouviez le suivant attention vous
êtes très didier
[Applaudissements]
et voilà vous avez gagné tout finalement
la fille s'est engagé à trouver dit-il à
une crise grave
et comme quoi la vie est injuste c'est
damien bravo vous avez gagné le blind
test on vous remercie tous d'avoir
participé à cette émission attention
attention spéciale fis ce soir c'est
normal c'était une émission spéciale
ific didier
[Musique]
et pour animer et arbitrer le blind
thèse j'appelle moi je suis enfui pour
quoi
[Applaudissements]
n'est ce pas
bah
et
on les voit
je passais dominique segall nom bien
alors alors pas pour justin je suis venu
avec de deux jeunes acolytes qui vont
m'aider à comptabiliser les points
magnifiques où ricco qui est de ce côté
ci qui va vite compris qu ici ici sean
chaque cliché et si on te demande
étoiles et plus belle fille tu lèves et
tu n'es verrai où autant je le sais au
brésil
bon donc on va jouer le brésil ici voilà
brésil contre l'italie puisque l'italie
elles sont belles aussi comme daniel
voilà attention daniel il faut gagner ce
soir aussi daniel sait pas tout d'avoir
été champion du monde de handball faut
gagner au blind test maintenant c'est
pas comme ça bousille est aujourd'hui
que je suis à cyril quels étaient les
points avec d'errance de côté ses jolis
vins et des choeurs ça va être très dur
bien donc il ya filles dans le but
moi ce que je vous demande c'est
l'interprétation de garde du coeur
aujourd'hui didier
[Musique]
tieger
l'équipe c'est l'équipe
one
voilà très bien voilà vous êtes fort les
mecs attention 2 10
[Musique]
comme quoi l'arbitrage vidéo a du bon
bah oui parce que voyez comme quoi on
peut faire des énormes erreurs parce que
moi je pensais qu'il allait me c'est
pourquoi je fais des déchets que ce jour
36 challenge alain fauquet italie brésil
a offert une rose à windows alors s'il
vous plaît ne s'appelle chain et
regardant pousser le garçon oui parce
que tu peux faire un cadeau ouvrir
l'oeil c'est touchant regarde bien un
pétale bruno witek arrive demain
d'affaires m'arrive de me les enfants
continuent chanson numéro coutadeur
choisir
alors attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
connaître sa boucle
ouais
[Applaudissements]
laisse tomber je suis c'est salut les
copains mandat
alors brésil italie 3
lamanda faudra venir habiter un petit
peu en france soit meilleur
mais en france ça passe votre culture
française aux états unis donc une âme
avec nico je peux le faire si elle me
donné tes seins de wall street
commençait pas mélanger les points
attention attention
[Musique]
oui l'interprète avec mes filles je me
laissais
je ne
aucun
oh
aller chez moi ou faire grand bruit dans
le monde beaucoup
j'avais peur
vasselle que
croyez
jeunes
un bon je vais vous le dire si c'est un
film non le public quand vous écoutez x
m6 qui a dit philippe lavil là avec les
filles
attentif aux côtes il faut pas
la bravo bravo vous appelez comment bon
maintenant qu'ils nous avaient
déshabillé attendez vous connaissez la
règle du jeu bravoure tous les corps
l'applaudît voilà très bien alors
attention continue didier six
pour déstabiliser
cette vallée de la seine
louis
monsieur k
auj
egk égard déjà dans qu'italie 4 brésil
un polo d'apparat c'est le mauvais bonds
chanson numéro 7
[Musique]
attention car jugé jeudi au public je
connais toute l'oeuvre de david haye en
concert je sais que j'ai lu c'est 106e
cm
on sait simplement jeudi au public si
vous répondez
ah non vous laissiez répondre les
invités ci répondra vous répondez didier
[Musique]
c'est à voir
non
je
le mans bleus à toutes les filles
cet été
jean ministre vis des autres cantons le
monsieur votre vidéo sinon ce contrôle
s'est effectivement félix gray et didier
barbelivien la règle après deux belles
chances la musique
je suis
[Musique]
voilà alors serge bruno solo ouais ouais
je vis un résident de haut niveau
affectivement
[Musique]
jean joly
mc saïda
là
ici ce brésil 2 est bonne didier
[Musique]
tu parles
eddy mitchell oui
martin reviendra jeudi
que des bons bravo mais comment vous
connaissez tous à martin c'est bien
bravo ça se voit martin vous êtes vous
voulez pas fait appel aux pilotes
isabelle aux rays contente on continue
olivier
alors c'est comme ça
[Musique]
gentil une fois qu'ils ont reconnu tarek
parce que c'est gentil italie ben si
c'est le brésil rencontre avec trois
points grâce à notre ami bruno solo qui
a reconnu il était une fois je vous
félicite bruno solo parce que j'avais
pas beaucoup de disques adorait jeunes
ça va non il ya la question est très
bien chez moi donc delà du foot didier
[Musique]
non pas
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que franchement cyndi lauper
dit
[Applaudissements]
pour moi c'est sûr en charge de toys et
chaussées sur l'eau sans changement pour
moi c'est ok je voulais déjà pas
beaucoup mais on attend des cadeaux
canaux d'achat
jade olivier est vrai parce que là et là
c'est vraiment dur là non
il s'appelle déjà ça
[Musique]
c'est donner ce clash à genève publient
la gécamines
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais j'suis désolé si elle une colline
va bien entendu aylwin collins n'est pas
michael like you pay demoiselle vous
venez venez ici venez ici il ya eu six
brésil 4 bravo vous appelez comment
comptez-vous alès véronique mahdia alors
là maintenant nous arrivons à la fin de
ce blind test et celui ou celle qui va
trouver ben finalement c'est super mango
bien que quelques étés les résultats
auparavant celui ou celle qui trouvent
ça gagne de blind test c'est injuste
c'est aussi l'avis émane véronique et
marche est partie
attention c'est le super banco didier
[Musique]
madonna est à présent
je suis bon public et la nina non mais
t'as dis c'était quoi
m
[Musique]
le gardien de stoke sur péno
gagné mais pourquoi continue sa razzia
dans une équipe ça va les gars gagnent
c'est extraordinaire d'avoir une faune a
fait gagner le brésil donc le brésil
gagne aventure c'est le blind test
un blind test ce soir en hommage à
charles trenet donc nous entendrons des
reprises de chansons de charles trenet
par d'autres interprètes
est ce que je vous demanderai à vous
tous ici c'est de me donner les
interprètes bien entendu parce que les
titres des chansons les connaît oui mais
d'abord pour animer et arbitrer ce blind
test match au filet pourquoi tu là
et par-dessus moi y'a de la joie et du
soleil dans les
joie
toulouse
mon papa me l'essentiel c'est l'amour
c'est l'amour
bonjour bonjour les deux modèles partout
jana
bien alors on finit à djouba c'est
dommage parce que j'ai vu que l'art est
super cool y est haïtien ah ben oui
quand il est arrivé
donc est ce qu'on peut en mettre un tout
le monde ah oui même à nouer et on a
joué ce soir non puisque c'est charles
trenet le soleil qui avait rendez vous
avec la ville d'accord ça te plait ça
tire et ça me plaît beaucoup la
jusqu'ici tout va bien je trouve tes
amis franchement alors gina qui est une
jeune chanteuse nadia qui l'a bien voilà
et voilà voilà bien alors attention et
soleil ici c'est le soleil on joue et on
et vous avec la lune hard ou à lui très
bien philips est parfait jusqu'ici
merci on commence didier premières
chansons
non
[Musique]
oui c'est compliqué vous avez dit vous
avez dit eddy mitchell et vous avez dit
claude françois et vous avez tous raison
parce qu'effectivement c'est eddy
mitchell et claude françois
donc un partout donc en a partout bravo
glycine ont mis un point ici et ici là
nous deuxième chanson didier sur le toit
de l'hôtel legends gisèle être rejeté
mais chanter
les chatteries chatte mes chats souris 3
me
[Musique]
en ce cas olalala venez un peu gêné mais
si vous avez comme en première fois à
troyes c'est chaud ce soir j'avais dit
non non non non c'est parce qu'on a
dribblé attention attention attention
marie gilles a régné tout serge est ce
qu'on peut faire un petit rythme s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
les voici
je suis désolé ça vous aura permis de
mieux connaître en même temps les
barbots le contrôle vidéo jacques bravo
donc ça fait un ami ou sur les points là
de l eelam m2a et les luttes mène par 2
points parce qu'on soutient que les
voies douala très bien bien
alors didier deschamps sont ils et
autres machines non le nom des six jours
bien bien des qualités par magie
l'égalité barrett a une vraie culture à
cultiver à des prix bien franc continue
une quatre billets
[Musique]
suite
non
bien je te préviens bien sans son numéro
[Musique]
la tour
mais ta mère
[Applaudissements]
voir
avait réussi
non maintenant maintenant c'est pas dans
le comté juste pour voir comme ça c'est
à ces enjeux les deux camps mais
maintenant c'est passé très compliqué je
vous envoie juste les écouter didier
louis iv une version de la main
c'est
les prix n'ont hélas le pas
le prénom est français incroyable mais
vrai vous connaissez ça vous c'est
incroyable vous appelez comment émis la
bravoure et mims est une star maintenant
la 6 e à la 6
[Musique]
pourquoi
il ya urgence
mais
sacha distel
c'était plusieurs les gens plusieurs
sens
bayonne
on fait du cinéma le mauvais sort
les charlots
pour les collégiens oui mais les clichés
c'est fou comme vous êtes force un décor
de cinéma
ah c'est vous les regardez chez nous on
connaît les charlots elle pour l'instant
il gagne la liga c'est l'une à combler
sont là trois pour les soleils et 4 pour
les lunes chance qu'elle met recettes
didier très complications
le travail en amont
très compliqué c'est un brésilien titi
[Musique]
alors
gilbert toro bravo titoff c'est très peu
connu pourquoi j'ai l'air
quelle musique que j'écoute c'est vrai
on lui fait un compliment et c'est
pourquoi j'ai l'air non non non c'est la
violence est génial tient aussi de
berthod bravo alors maintenant chanson
numéro huit du viè camp
[Applaudissements]
alors
j'en reviens pas georges bel âge que
vous avez laissé savoir si votre papa
écouter ça non son fiancé qui est plus
là tu sais que ça te va très bien la
lune comme ça didier je voudrais qu'on
passe à la chanson numéro 10
[Musique]
on
mon temps m
[Applaudissements]
on peut lancer québécois est belle jeune
fille blonde trouviez ça c'est son
fiancé l'a si vous trouvez ça vous est
forte
didier mais voilà la petite chanson là
qui vient dans le dit cela
[Musique]
c'est miharu cauchy la barbe à papa
personnes connaissaient vraiment je
crois qu'avec béatrice qui connaît sa
wii pour l'instant à égalité à l'année
ou égalité parfaite en salle on va
arriver au super banco alors attention
super banco didier ile de france
[Musique]
très dur
ce qu'ils voulaient
[Musique]
et
mariage de lui
[Musique]
m
pour commencer centre chaleur la douleur
ça dure
pourtant les hommes de retrouver comme
tout et sauva les luttes de tous nous
retrouver
dans le titre du groupe y allument
jamais bien nantis d'euros
[Musique]
c'est très durement franchement j'ai un
très dur ce sont les tueurs de la lune
de miel qu'il avait dit avait alors t'as
pas vu du maintien vient camarades
manola cette non mais tu l'avais dit
vraiment oui c'est bien comment tu les
connais ben si les bons chanteurs
voiture je me sens beaucoup de braga
merci merci beaucoup merci à tous
c'était donc une égalité parfaite et
maintenant on passe au blind test
un blindtest ya la spéciale baiser avec
philippe camphil bisous
le bisou
maisons ensevelies
comment ça va se passer alors alors
aujourd'hui on va jouer les grandes
bouches contre les petites bouches
oui alors puisque c'est des baisers les
grandes bouches sont ici d'accord et les
petites bouches montrer qu'on sait beau
on les petites jolie liane foly alors
préféré grande bouchaoui d'accord va
changer d'avis les grandes bouches
céliane polybenne changer les filles
marie line change avec nadia voilà bah
là bravo philippe attention tout le
monde est prêt didier
or
non
je
géniale idée des films en langues et a
très bien répondu jean normand
libération c'est c'est hors concours
maintenant on va voir comme ça c'est
didier si tu veux bien me laisser
pendant une journée
[ __ ]
m
métiers de bouche non non non non non
c'est bien chez les dames c'est la
version originale donc on est toujours
dans les baisers les baisers deuxième
pour le mans pour le moment c'est vous
qui gagnez vous avez marqué un point
oui c'est hors concours tensions
internes aussi leur concours en sicile
bouche du nez une bouche d'honneur voilà
et maintenant donc on passait
[Musique]
non
ces lignes alors en équipe êtes un génie
absolu c'est tout le fun exagérons rien
à bercy ensuite si pour moi chanson
numéro 3
[Musique]
quelqu'un qui se cherche toujours
la phase i de frei et
les yeux
au quartier dillon quoi quand il veut et
quand j'ai vu leur oui tu ne rentres de
moha d'accord j'y leurs odeurs comme ça
la laiterie de leur savoir oui mais
original un coup franc de wendel a
repris penseur il ya quelques temps je
suis se sentir que là c'était les soeurs
et des petits malgaches vous que les
sony cherche les tout petits malgaches
vous souvenez de saint-serge des soeurs
et donc voilà bravo laurent ruquier donc
je pense que ça fait trois points pour
les grandes bouches du rhône est une
grand bol petit à bush jeudi qu'il
comptait pas encore dépassée si intense
et c'était un truc de fou
or ne criez pas se louper
[Applaudissements]
m
ils ont beau chanteur n'est pas fiers de
notre côté
dans ces petites bouches marque un point
les grandes bouches ont déjà je pas
combien excusez moi je suis désolé
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure c'est simple
injuste parce que tout à l'heure la la
la demoiselle a à trouver et 2 points
pour le petit bouche quatre points pour
les grandes banques
maintenant si didier
m
[Musique]
le tfc j'ai rencontré les bouches contre
éléments très vous avez vous fait
pourquoi grande bouche bée mouche
puisque il faut connaître ses jours
c'est jérôme le regretter ses joueurs le
regretter c'est jérôme absolument et de
regretter c'est jérôme didier 7
je connais pas oui c'était
c'est normal
non non
[Musique]
or
à
incroyable qu'il a reconnu bill blass
moi idiot cellule marc convaincu dassier
après ouais alors non vous rentrez pas
leur chance au numéro 8
j'hésite russie de sochaux
[Musique]
alain chamfort marimekko chômage est
offert la victoire j'en reprendrais bien
c'est possible parce que la boue nous
arrêter là tout à l'heure
on s'est fié de tisane comme j'ai pu
ramasser
didier hamon c'est marqué dessus
[Musique]
attention finir par avoir haute c'est
plus dur commence
[Musique]
m
serge je demande avec les vidéos parce
que j'entends du haka d'un côté ceux qui
gagnent de l'eau retirer sa chute après
plein à temps sur dur
[Musique]
[ __ ] aure atika dix travaux
[Applaudissements]
arcane arcade c'est un joli pourrait
nous dire ah regagne c'est un dangereux
ennemi dangereux criminels c'était le
sien serbe
j'étais petit arcadis est ta culture ce
qui se passe si j'avais les mains d'un
côté de pierre perret la main sur non
maîtrise pas le français mais non mairie
serait passé si j'ai peur qu'on est là
voila voila ma fille on n'a pas vu notre
gueule de piano à queue au nom diffusée
à ripley on se trouve on va enfin vous
avez vous coucher le soir bien attention
maintenant alors attendez j'explique
aulas le super banco
quand vous perdez pour le moment mais si
vous trouvez super banco on pouvait tout
gagner demain on peut défaire juste au
ras mais la vie je peux expliquer aussi
ça la vie est injuste comme ce jeu
attention celui qui répond gagne tout
didier
les gens non je n'y avais qui attendait
à mi septembre comme confus ne triche
pas de briller
il ya des champs
attendez la mer
j'aime burkina
[Musique]
lens
louis j
c'est tous
sur ces 12
tous les maux on est pour
tous ses jetons alors il fait quelqu'un
c'est dans public qui non non non non
non tout le monde cherche encore
si si si si le tandem là c'est vous qui
gagnez ben oui puisqu'ils l'ont pas ils
sont pas servis du superbe hambourg est
pour l'instant qu'au dit waouh je suis
désolé pour vous il fait exploser par
les grandes bouches voilà et politiques
bougez bibi
[Applaudissements]
non
omar s'appelle omar
sur glane caisse maintenant dernière
séquence cette émission je reconnais
qu'on équilibre un peu les équipes là
ses invités moi je suis tenu la voilà
en bien alors c'est un blind test
spécial drague donc et j'appelle pour
arbitrer ce blind test martiaux philippe
aux antilles
[Musique]
je
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
lortie le monsieur
attention ça lui va bien
roderick n ont même pas qu'elle
et les gars alors blindtest précieuse
rag vous êtes prêt drogue
alors attention jouez joie ya deux
champions comme wind est donc les rouges
contre les dorer d'accord rincez bien
d'accord c'est bien attention didier
premier morceau
m
on attendait non mais énorme cité bâtie
au blender là vous allez mon admiration
absolue pour guy lamy est le sillage
d'un mécénat ou bien alors je veux
évidemment que l'interprète 1
l'interprète
nous resterons calmes et nous restons
dignes face evolis les amériques du
match
evelyne thomas plus tôt donc bravo donc
ça fait un point marqué pour cette
équipe la caisse elle est commandée doré
doré doré par robert louis dreyfus
alors attention je veux l'interprète
ressent son numéro deux
[Applaudissements]
c'est
l'état
avec de l'air
vdb les lots non
j'avais dit marc beuls et ça
un touché
cyclo alors c'est pas lady marmalade
sait si c'est la chanson l'agent suisse
et monsieur s'est bâti label voilà
zéro pointé
heureusement de nombreuses critiques et
là je vois bien alors maintenant on
continue chanson numéro trois
interprètes
[Musique]
enfin pour eux
plus pas trop dur comme
oui
non
bosch numéro 5
[Musique]
ce genre bande à michel c'est comment
vous vous trouvez pas tu m'avais moi
j'ai dit avant je tenais une chanson
exactement et connexes qui chante lui
c'est une honte
le résultat c'est déjà beaucoup c'est
vrai ça fait 3 pour les rouges a pour
l'ego et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'en ris l'om gagne et c'est un sens oui
il ya trois rouges est double il vient
de marquer le récit qui cherche un
buteur bien en continu didier 7 et 10
aïe aïe aïe alors là ça y est c'est pour
mille
il est sympa c'est adrian séverac gaza
ont continué cette 4c que les trucs et
18 ans n'ont à la base
bonjour je sais pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah la la
le président nathan sinon and guns n' a
coûté 600 millions le club
oh
c'est bien mais google n'a franchement
c'est comme avec l'ol il ya pas beaucoup
de joueurs qui changent la sm5 les
rouges et hazard c'est pas bon michel
ange est donné à tous parce que sinon on
la rassure en se pensant
il
c'est
m
bien qu'elle ait le résultat donc police
ils ont partagé ce volet m'adapter
circule sur la partie alors les dorer
vous avez 3 vous avez fait un bon point
les dorer trois buts qu'on était là et
je dois dire par robert louis dreyfus et
les routes
oui mais mais maintenant voilà il ya une
règle dans ce jeu qui est complètement
ce type et c'est réglé le super banco
c'est à dire qu'en fait quelle que soit
l'équipe qui gagne et si celui qui
répond si bordeaux gagne tout voilà
c'est bien voilà les chances et le monde
sa mort vous avez tout fait tout ça pour
rien la vie est injuste c'est ben voilà
donc attention didier jeu nous
interprète la barrière
nous avons fait
koné
alors
oui
l'ol a perdu vous avez bien joué quand
même bravo qui sera merci à tous voilà
m
alors nous allons faire ce soir un blind
test spécial pluie inutile d'expliquer
pourquoi
mais pour arbitrer le blind test
j'appelle bon si on fait les beaux ortiz
m
mais attention spéciale cuir aujourd'hui
on va jouer avec les ombres est
évidemment très sombre et le chinois la
rebond soir alors je vous présente
delphine ici en blanc oui et puis la
jolie nadia aussi on en voit très bien
donc on joue les couleurs contre le
blanc d'accord donc c'est spécial puis
vous connaissez le principe vous me
donnez l'interprète évidemment pas du
tout le titre de la chanson uniquement
l'interprète de la de la chanson
[Applaudissements]
c
le lait
fastoche à wellsville plus facile de
gérer des sternes justement paris c'est
toujours attention didier
[Musique]
ces deux verres par jour ou la nuit
bien ça fait un partout donc merci la
vache est d'accord ce qu'ils ont marqué
des points
on continue didier brink's plie aux bras
je demande un replay je veux revoir ça
je vous ressentiez vous demandons un
écho à la pièce où le premier accord ils
voient que les prix serge khalfon s'il
vous plaît ripley dont on continue
didier attention regardez le regardait
ce plu
[Musique]
bien alors l'interprète
oui oui l'interprète
non
c'est la farce
la musique de votre époque tu auras
encore pire ce qui arrive la vie d un
terme à trois diplômés
oui j'en sois numéro six loups garous
c'est très fort ce soir dernier ces
univers visuel
[Musique]
oh
bravo
c'est un roman je décris profile déjà un
jeu d'équilibriste
le collectif fonctionne en battant
samedi à aimé jacquet
si des défauts
non
c'est fort ça qu'ici
et bah oui les chansons et les écrivent
l'habitude d'être ouvert alors la suite
didier il pleuvait pas
quatre vieux le chômage
j'existe à dix on chez arthur d
john danks bien maintenant il ya le
super bowl c'est la règle du jeu ce qui
se trouve le super banco gagne tout même
si l'organisme attend avec lg miel crois
quoi lui
c'est injuste mais superbe on connaît
attends attends attends
genève
m
ap
[Musique]
et y parvenir
je dis pas
[Musique]
m
1 2
me brun de nous appeler comment philippe
mais c'est qui l'éruption est à même ce
jour
[Musique]
concernant l'emploi
bic et de la chance qu'ils avaient de
fort à faire avec de superbes entourage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]